* Sanfte Musik *
Die afrikanischen Sonnenaufgänge
und Sonnenuntergänge
sind einfach unschlagbar.
Als ich ein Kind war,
hatte ich eine Cousine,
die ein Kitschbild gemalt hat
mit einem afrikanischen
Sonnenuntergang.
Eine typische Savanne
mit den Akazien.
Ich wollte auch immer nach Afrika
in den Dschungel.
Das hat sich ganz tief
bei mir im Kopf verankert.
Und, obwohl wir jetzt schon
acht Jahre da sind,
kommt mir dieses Bild
jedes Mal in den Sinn.
Und jedes Mal, wenn wir am Abend
von der Arbeit nach Hause kommen,
wenn wir früh genug
nach Hause kommen,
setze ich mich hin
und sehe den Sonnenuntergang an.
Es ist schon ein Wunder der Natur
und eine wahnsinnige Schönheit.
Aber der Alltag im Paradies
ist auch unberechenbar.
Christians Frau Misha ist Notärztin
bei der Okavango Air Rescue
Ihr Tag beginnt ganz anders.
Wir wurden heute Morgen
um 6.30 Uhr aus dem Bett gerufen
für einen möglichen
Helikoptereinsatz im Delta,
wo sich ein kleines Mädchen
am Bein verletzt hat,
und der Vater besteht darauf,
dass ein Arzt das anschaut.
Wir haben gesagt:
"Okay, wir können sofort fliegen."
Wir haben einen Kostenvoranschlag
gemacht,
weil es
kein lebensbedrohlicher Notfall ist
und haben jetzt -
lass mich auf die Uhr gucken -
2 Std. später das Okay bekommen.
Wir dürfen kommen, aber nicht jetzt,
weil die Gäste jetzt
auf einen Game Drive gehen.
Wir sollten doch
gegen 12 Uhr dort landen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Im Okavango-Delta in Botswana können
vermögende Touristen aus aller Welt
eine Vielzahl an wilden Tieren
beobachten.
Game Drives heissen die Safari-
Fahrten in gesicherten Fahrzeugen.
* Anregende Musik *
Wenn diese Gäste nach
der Schweizer Rettungsfirma rufen,
weiss Misha nie genau,
was sie erwartet:
eine lebensbedrohliche Verletzung
oder eine Bagatelle.
Im Mittleren Westen der USA
ist Tornadosaison.
Seit einer Woche fahren
die Fribourger Dominic und Sascha
durch das grosse Land,
jagen Gewitterzellen
und wollen unbedingt einen Tornado
vor ihre Fotolinse bekommen.
Physiklehrer Dominic hat ein Gewitter
entdeckt, das es in sich hat.
Potztausend!
Es gibt zwar keinen Niederschlag,
das ist spannend.
Die Windstärke ist unglaublich.
Vor ihren Augen entwickelt sich
die perfekte Ausgangslage
für einen Tornado.
Und das nur
ein paar Kilometer entfernt.
Die beiden können es nicht glauben.
Oh, 10 %.
So etwas gab es
in den letzten Jahren noch nie.
Das ist unglaublich.
Das löst Staunen aus.
Jetzt nur keine Zeit verlieren:
Während Sascha
das Mietauto bereitmacht,
prüft Dominic,
was seine Konkurrenten -
die professionellen Stormchaser -
vorhaben.
Ich schaue noch kurz
die Chase-Versammlung an.
Nicht alle
haben die Signale eingeschaltet.
Aber diese hier
sind z.B. schon unterwegs.
Es gibt jene,
die die Signale erst einschalten,
wenn sie wissen,
dass sie am richtigen Ort sind.
Wenn sie falsch sind,
geben sie keine Signale.
Ich hoffe, dass nicht bereits zu
viele vor Ort sind oder sein werden.
Aber die Lage ist so klar,
wo man hinmuss.
Das Tornadojagen
ist in den USA Volkssport.
Meteorologen,
Hobbyfotografen, Journalisten
und ganze Busladungen von Touristen:
Alle wollen den Nervenkitzel
eines möglichst mächtigen Tornados
hautnah miterleben.
Schau dir diese Autos an!
Und Storm-Hunters sind auch hier.
Schau, Storm-Hunters.
Soll ich ihm
unsere Visitenkarte geben?
Die beiden Schweizer
halten sich von der Masse fern.
Sie wollen
ihren eigenen Tornado finden.
Vielleicht hat es auch
mit Stolz zu tun,
einen eigenen Tornado zu haben.
Wir möchten mehr oder weniger
nicht mit dem Mainstream mitgehen.
Ich glaube,
hier sind wir sehr gut positioniert.
Jetzt müssen wir warten,
was er macht.
Er soll wachsen und gross werden,
erwachsen werden.
Dann gibt es hoffentlich
einen Tornado.
Sonntagmorgen in Osttimor,
Südostasien.
Daniel Moser und seine Familie
widmen diese Zeit Gott -
in der Hauskirche,
gemeinsam mit Freunden.
Vater, ich bin dir dankbar,
dass ich dich Vater nennen darf.
Dankbar,
dass du mir ein guter Vater bist
und ich mit dir
in einer Beziehung sein darf.
Es ist wunderbar, dass du
mich akzeptierst, so wie ich bin.
Ich muss dir nichts beweisen,
sondern kann immer zu dir kommen.
Danke, dass du heute
für uns da bist. Amen.
* Babyquengeln *
Die Kirche ist für mich
etwas völlig Normales.
Dazu pflege ich eine Beziehung.
Wir sprechen über das,
was wir praktizieren.
Wir haben einen Glauben,
der uns vereint.
Der christliche Gedanke dahinter
ist, dass wir anderen helfen wollen.
Um anderen helfen zu können,
müssen wir mit uns im Reinen sein
und uns klar sein, was wir
auf den Tisch bringen können.
Ein Teil davon ist, unsere Schwächen
zu erkennen und daran zu arbeiten.
# You say I am loved
when I can't feel a thing.
Daniel ist überzeugter Christ.
Vor acht Jahren
hatte er ein Erlebnis,
das sein Leben
für immer verändert hat.
Damals war er Fallschirmaufklärer
für die Schweizer Armee.
Es war eine spezielle Begegnung.
Wir waren mit der KFOR
im Kosovo im Einsatz.
Bei einem Ferienflug
sass ich im Flieger.
Die Tür beim Cockpit war nicht zu,
je nach Links- oder Rechtskurve
schwenkte sie auf und zu.
Wir flogen durch die Wolken.
In diesem Moment
hörte ich eine Stimme.
Das erlebte ich
vorher und nachher nie mehr.
Ich hörte: "Möchtest du fliegen?
Möchtest du für mich fliegen?"
Ich wusste, das war Gott.
Ich hatte nichts dagegen und sagte:
"Ja, ich versuche es."
Achte Jahre später
sind wir hier gelandet.
So wird Daniel Pilot
bei der Mission Aviation Fellowship,
einer christlichen Hilfsorganisation.
Seit vier Jahren
lebt er ein Leben als Missionar.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das Wort wird oft falsch verstanden.
Für mich ist das mein Glaube
und mein Leben.
Und es gibt
viele verschiedene Arten,
wie ein Christ
seinen Glauben auslebt.
Ob jemand eine Kirche aufbaut
oder ob jemand
ganz praktisch fliegt.
Was auch immer:
Es spielt keine Rolle.
* Funkspruch auf Englisch *
Der Inselstaat Osttimor liegt in
Südostasien nördlich von Australien.
Er ist nur ein Drittel so gross
wie die Schweiz
und hat gut 1 Mio. Einwohner
I should be there in about
20-25 minutes. So it's all good.
* Sanfte Musik *
Täglich ist Daniel mit der Realität
im drittärmsten Land der Welt
konfrontiert.
Seine Arbeit ist hier bitter nötig.
Ein Neugeborenes hat zu wenig Blut.
Es muss so schnell wie möglich
ins Krankenhaus der Hauptstadt Dili
gebracht werden.
Do you have one clip?
Or is it in the door?
Ein Rettungswagen braucht
über die Bergstrassen 3-4 Std.
Der Flug wird keine 30 Min. dauern.
Diese Zeit entscheidet oft
über Leben und Tod.
* Bedrückende Musik *
* Funkspruch auf Englisch *
Viele Familien leben
in kleinen Dörfern ausserhalb.
Osttimor ist dringend
auf ausländische Hilfsorganisationen
angewiesen.
Das Land ist erst seit 2002
eigenständig.
Vieles funktioniert noch nicht so,
wie es sollte.
* Er spricht Portugiesisch. *
Am Flughafen sollte das Baby
möglichst schnell ins Krankenhaus
transportiert werden.
Aber der Krankenwagen
ist noch nicht da.
Wir hoffen, dass die Ambulanz kommt.
Es ist stressig,
hier auf die Ambulanz zu warten.
Wenn ich ein Kind habe,
das röchelt ...
... beginnt es bei mir zu rumoren.
Dann rufe ich die Ambulanz an,
bis sie kommt.
Manchmal haben sie keinen Fahrer,
manchmal ist der Wagen kaputt.
Das macht mir schon Mühe.
Ah, they're coming.
Endlich:
Daniel kann den kleinen Patienten
den Rettungssanitätern übergeben.
Wenn ich mich
zu stark hineinsteigern würde,
wäre ich jetzt zu Hause.
Ich kann mich nicht
über jedes Schicksal informieren
und mich dafür interessieren.
Wenn sie
die Türen schliessen und abfahren,
versuche ich, damit abzuschliessen.
Merlo am Fusse der Anden.
Gestern überquerte der Ostschweizer
Stefan Zeberli mit seinem Ballon
die Gebirgskette auf 7'000 m Höhe.
Heute soll's entspannter
zu und her gehen -
mit einer Fahrt über das
Weinanbaugebiet von Mendoza.
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
Am Mittag gab es plötzlich
viel thermischen Wind.
Dadurch gab es
eine gewisse Erwärmung.
Das ist nicht optimal,
um Ballon zu fahren.
Stefan ist einer
der weltbesten Piloten.
Aber die Verhältnisse
in den Bergen Argentiniens
sind nicht zu vergleichen
mit dem Wind in den Schweizer Alpen.
Hier kreuzen sich
verschiedene Zugwinde.
Ab einer gewissen Höhe
kann das gefährlich werden.
* Funkspruch *
Verstanden, wir sind startklar.
Wir brauchen ca. 15 Sek. Vorlauf.
Ja, das ist gut.
Wir sind gestartet.
* Langgezogener Ton,
vereinzelte Klänge *
Schon mit etwa sechs oder sieben
wollte ich Ballonfahrer werden.
Als ich Kind war,
gab es in der Schweiz
einen Boom mit Heissluftballons.
Im Thurgau, wo ich aufgewachsen bin,
gab es extrem viele Ballonfahrer.
In diesem Gebiet
ist das Ballonfahren optimal.
Schon mit sechs oder sieben
war für mich klar,
dass ich mit 16 anfangen werde,
Ballon zu fahren.
Das war mein Traum.
Meine Eltern haben mich unterstützt.
Sie sagten immer: "Mach das."
Wir wohnten auf einem Bauernhof,
hatten eigenes Land.
Ich baute Gemüse an.
Ich habe das dann verkauft und habe
bereits im Schulalter Geld verdient.
So konnte Stefan
seinen Traum verwirklichen.
Mit 16 hat er
seinen ersten Ballon gekauft.
Bis heute
hat er über 2'000 Fahrten gemacht,
ist siebenfacher Schweizermeister und
vierfacher Europameister geworden.
Die Faszination ist heute dieselbe
wie damals als kleiner Bub.
Mit dem Spiel des Windes, dem Wetter
und der Natur nah verbunden zu sein.
(Mann via Funk) Dann gehen wir hoch.
- Ja.
Steigen wir weiter. Bis jetzt ...
Jetzt passiert etwas bei mir.
Die Anden erzeugen
ab einer gewissen Höhe Windwirbel,
die dem Ballon
ordentlich zusetzen können.
Stefan weiss nicht, in welcher Höhe
die Turbulenzen auftauchen
und wie stark sie sein werden.
Jetzt kannst du wieder brennen.
Wie hoch sind wir?
- 2'600.
Jetzt kann es kurz
ungemütlich werden.
* Sanfte Musik *
Jonas Langenegger
hat einen grossen Traum:
Er will Schweizermeister
im Segelkunstflug werden.
Seit er mit 15 zum ersten Mal
in einem Segelflugzeug sass,
lässt ihn diese Art des Fliegens
nicht mehr los.
Ich fliege schon seit zehn Jahren.
Ich kann es kaum glauben.
Wenn man mal angefangen hat
und drin ist ...
Es sind die Leute,
es ist das Fliegen.
Wenn man zum Himmel schaut
und die Wolken sieht,
möchte man am liebsten
in den Flieger sitzen.
Jonas fährt fast jedes Wochenende
auf den Flugplatz, um zu trainieren.
Heute kann der 25-Jährige
ein grosszügiges Erbe antreten.
Hast du den Wohnwagen
nicht mehr gebraucht?
So zwei- bis dreimal im Jahr.
- Okay.
Jonas bekommt einen alten Wohnwagen
direkt beim Flugplatz Amlikon
geschenkt.
Ich bin 45 Jahre lang geflogen
und bin schon älter,
habe andere Hobbys.
Ich gebe das gerne
einem Jungen weiter.
Du kannst sagen, was du möchtest.
Ich bin grundsätzlich um alles froh,
das noch drin ist.
Von daher ... Ja.
Es ist cool.
Jetzt kann der Wahlzürcher
auch hier wohnen und übernachten,
wenn er an den Wochenenden
für die Schweizermeisterschaft
im Segelkunstflug trainiert.
Da kann man nur davon träumen.
Einen Wohnwagen einzurichten,
wenn man oft auf dem Flugplatz ist,
ist viel wert.
Eigentlich lebt Jonas
mit seiner Freundin Anna
im zürcherischen Effretikon.
Anna unterstützt ihren Freund
bei seinem aufwendigen Hobby.
V.a. an den Wochenenden muss sie aber
oft auf ihn verzichten.
Das Segelfliegen
gehört zu seinem Leben.
Das ist seine Leidenschaft.
Er könnte nicht ohne
das Segelfliegen sein.
Das ist auch schön.
Dabei blüht er auf.
Er ist auch erfolgreich dabei.
Da bin ich natürlich stolz.
Die Jungflieger sind
eine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft,
die Jonas extrem wichtig ist.
Hier fühlt er sich zu Hause.
Es ist schön, dass der Tag
nach dem Fliegen weitergeht:
zusammenzusitzen
und zusammen Abend zu essen.
Und nicht einfach Flieger wegpacken
und nach Hause gehen. Oder, Philipp?
Flieger wegpacken
und nach Hause gehen.
Trotz aller Geselligkeit: In Jonas
steckt ein ehrgeiziger Pilot.
An der Schweizermeisterschaft
in einer Woche will er beweisen,
dass er sich weiterentwickelt hat.
Er wagt den grossen Sprung
in die höchste Kategorie, Unlimited.
Bis ein Anruf
sein grosses Ziel zunichte macht.
Der Organisator teilt ihm mit,
dass die Kategorie Unlimited
in diesem Jahr
nicht durchgeführt werden kann.
Ich bin der einzige Teilnehmer
bei Unlimited.
Wenn ich allein
bei Unlimited fliege,
kann ich nicht
Schweizermeister werden.
Ja.
Ein harter Schlag für Jonas.
Scheinbar vergeblich hat er sich
drei Monate lang vorbereitet.
Ich habe dieses Jahr
extra für Unlimited trainiert.
Ich möchte gerne zeigen,
was ich geübt habe.
Und schauen, ob es gut ist. Ja.
* Melancholische Musik *
Die Tornadojäger Dominic und Sascha
hingegen sind ihrem Ziel näher:
Eine Gewitterzellen baut sich auf.
Wenn es das ist, dann ist es gut.
Dann ist es gut.
Auch bei den anderen Sturmjägern
herrscht nun plötzlich
Aufbruchsstimmung.
Während des Tages muss man Hunderte
Entscheidungen treffen.
Bis man diese gefällt hat,
ist man voller Zweifel.
Es können vier Superzellen
unterwegs sein,
und eine davon wirft den Tornado.
Welchen wähle ich nun?
Die grünen Punkte sind Stormchaser.
Unser Ziel ist:
weg von den Stormchasern.
Denn wir wollen
eine schöne Zelle haben
und sie am liebsten
für uns allein haben.
Während die anderen Tornadojäger
auf ein Gewitter im Norden setzen,
fahren die zwei Schweizer
ostwärts.
Roscoe -
das ist eine Ausfahrt vor Olchala
oder wie das heisst.
Ohlala.
- Ohlala, das klingt gut.
# Ohlala, jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt geht es nur noch darum,
rechtzeitig am richtigen Ort zu sein.
Hier ist eine schlimme Zelle
unterwegs.
Das könnte die stärkste Zelle sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie es ablaufen wird.
Verdammte Kackstrasse!
Tornadomeldung bestätigt. Zwei.
Jetzt ist es gelaufen.
Verdammt!
Jetzt ist der spannendste Moment
des Chasings:
Schaffen wir es oder nicht?
* Dramatische Musik *
Während seine Frau Misha
einen medizinischen Einsatz fliegt,
fährt Christian Gross
zu einem Schulhaus mitten im Delta.
Er und Misha haben das Projekt
gemeinsam geplant und bauen lassen.
Hier sollen schon bald die Kinder der
umliegenden Farmen zur Schule gehen.
Das Einzugsgebiet
beträgt mehrere Dutzend Kilometer.
Das grosse Gebäude ist die Küche
mit einem Gemeinschaftsraum.
Rundherum
gibt es sieben Klassenzimmer.
Das sind die sieben obligatorischen
Schuljahre in Botswana.
Nur haben die Schweizer
noch keine Lehrer gefunden,
die hier unterrichten wollen.
Solange die Gebäude
noch leer stehen,
machen sich die Wildtiere gerne
an den Strohdächern zu schaffen.
Hier hat bereits einer
einen Teil Gras gefressen.
Mit seiner Okavango Air Rescue
hat Christian
ein erfolgreiches Unternehmen
aufgebaut.
Nun will er der Bevölkerung
von Botswana etwas zurückgeben.
Wir haben selber gebaut
mit unseren Leuten.
Das hat viele Kosten gespart und
wir wussten, wohin das Geld geht.
Letztes Jahr
gab es eine grosse Flut.
Wir hatten bei den Wasserlöchern
mit den Lastwagen Schwierigkeiten.
Wir brauchten ca. 100'000 Fr.
für den Transport.
Und etwa 200'000 Fr.
für das Material und den Bau.
Wer hier draussen im Busch
auf etwas wartet, braucht Geduld.
Aber Christian ist zuversichtlich,
dass die Lehrer
schon bald gefunden werden
und der Schulbetrieb beginnen kann.
Ein paar Kilometer
von Osttimors Hauptstadt entfernt
arbeitet Deborah Moser.
Die Frau von Missionspilot Daniel
kommt alle zwei Wochen hierher.
Sie hat eine Ausbildung
als Heilpädagogin
und hilft Menschen
mit einem Handicap.
Sohn Eli begleitet sie zur Arbeit.
Hey.
* Sie spricht Portugiesisch. *
Die Behinderten hier haben einen
anderen Stellenwert als bei uns.
Viele werden immer noch versteckt.
Sie müssen zu Hause arbeiten
und dürfen nicht zur Schule.
Darum ist es wichtig,
dass sie hierherkommen können.
Die Timoresinnen, die hier arbeiten,
machen es immer besser.
Bald braucht es uns nicht mehr,
das ist gut.
Aber jetzt können wir ihnen
noch etwas mitgeben.
Diese Stunden im Heim für Behinderte
bedeuten Deborah viel.
Sie geniesst die Abwechslung,
zu Hause ist sie mit Eli oft allein.
Deborah arbeitet ehrenamtlich. Sie
hat kein Arbeitsvisum für Osttimor.
* Sie singen ein Lied
auf Portugiesisch. *
Für mich ist es toll, weil ich das
in der Schweiz gelernt habe.
Es ist super, dass ich das
hier brauchen und machen kann.
* Sie singen ein Lied
auf Portugiesisch. *
Seit vier Jahren
leben Deborah und Daniel in Osttimor.
In einer Kultur,
die ihnen zu Beginn völlig fremd war.
Die Rolle der Frau
ist genau definiert.
Als Frau ist man hier jemand,
wenn man Kinder hat.
Sie sind oft in Gruppen unterwegs.
Eine Timoresin
kocht oder wäscht nie allein.
Es sind immer Schwestern, Tanten,
Mütter, Grossmütter, Kinder dabei.
Osttimor hat sich 2002
in einem Unabhängigkeitskrieg
von Indonesien getrennt.
Die Folgen dieses Krieges
sind bis heute spürbar.
Es ist ein Entwicklungsland.
Es wird oft als das ärmste Land
Südostasiens betitelt.
Der Mensch hat einen anderen Wert
als im Westen,
wo man alles dafür tut,
ein bis zwei Jahre mehr zu haben.
Ich schulde es der Bevölkerung,
hier dranzubleiben.
Es geht den Einwohnern, den Menschen
hier schon nicht sehr gut.
Schau, ein Hund.
Es gibt Dinge, die man
in die Schweiz mitnehmen kann.
Das einfache Leben, das Zeit haben.
Zu Hause hat man für nichts Zeit.
Hier nimmt man sich die Zeit.
"Was denkt der andere über mich?" -
so denkt man hier kaum.
Hier macht man einfach.
Andererseits können wir von ihnen
die Lebensfreude lernen.
Sie leben hier im Moment,
das gefällt mir.
Eli, der Sohn von Deborah und Daniel,
wächst in Osttimor auf.
Und der kleine Blondschopf
fällt hier auf.
Eli ist in dieser Kultur
schon ein Magnet.
Sie haben ein hartes Leben.
Wenn dann
ein Sonnenschein vorbeikommt,
dürfen sie
einen Strahl davon nehmen.
* Leichte Klänge *
In Botswana ist Misha unterwegs
zu einem medizinischen Einsatz.
Sie wurde in eine Safari Lodge
im Okavango Delta gerufen.
Hier soll sich das Kind von
US-Touristen am Bein verletzt haben.
Wie schlimm die Verletzung ist,
weiss die Notfallärztin nicht.
How are you?
Er weiss es nicht,
ich weiss es nicht.
Wir fahren jetzt zu einem Patienten
und schauen, was wir machen können.
Do you know where to go?
Der Ranger bringt Misha und ihr Team
in die Safari Lodge,
ein Luxushotel
mitten im Naturreservat.
Hallo, ich bin Dr. Misha.
Wir haben die Wunde
jeden Tag gereinigt und versorgt.
War das nicht genug?
Ich schickte meinem Arzt zu Hause
ein Bild.
Er meinte, es wäre besser,
wenn man es anschaut.
Hi, und du bist die arme Verletzte?
I'm Mary-Ann.
It doesn't really hurt.
Ich denke, wir gehen mal rein
und schauen uns das an.
Thanks very much for coming.
- No problem. Please come along.
Die Beinverletzung
ist nichts Schlimmes.
Zur Sicherheit will Misha dem Mädchen
aber eine Infusion
mit Antibiotika legen.
On three I put the needle in.
Don't count to three.
Then I know it's coming.
Come on, it's easy.
Schau einfach da rüber.
Es ist schon vorbei.
Hast du das überlebt?
Schon fertig. Okay?
We're going to clean it nicely
and put something around.
And it shall be fine.
Die Sache ist schnell erledigt.
Und das Team der Okavango Air Rescue
wird für seinen Einsatz
mit seltenem Besuch belohnt.
Elefanten trauen sich nicht oft
so nah an eine Safari Lodge heran.
Und kurz darauf geht es auch
schon wieder zurück zum Helikopter.
Das war jetzt vielleicht
etwas übertrieben,
aber ich bin recht optimistisch,
dass das wieder gut kommt.
Viele kleine Wunden starten so und
werden dann zum grossen Desaster
und enden dann
auf der Intensivstation.
Wie hoch sind wir?
- 2'600.
Stefan und sein Team sind derweilen
in ein paar heftige Turbulenzen
geraten.
Die unvorhersehbaren Zugwinde
über der argentinischen Hochebene
machen dem erfahrenen Piloten
zu schaffen.
Ich glaube ... wir bleiben ...
Wir haben eine Föhnsituation.
Der Wind macht Wellen gegen unten.
Diese Wellen
haben wir dreimal gespürt.
Je nachdem wie stark sie sind,
möchte ich nicht weiter rein.
To all ballons from Stefan:
The turbulences are really heavy.
Stefan ist als Erster gestartet.
Jetzt kann er seine Kollegen
vor den Turbulenzen warnen.
Irgendwann werden die Turbulenzen
gefährlich.
Noch weiter in die Hauptströmung
hochzugehen ...
Da kann es schon recht schütteln.
Jetzt können wir die schöne
Ballonfahrt weiter geniessen.
Ich mag es nicht, wenn es ...
* Sanfte, meditative Klänge *
Hola!
* Rauschen der Feuerzufuhr *
* Pfiff *
Der dort!
Zu viert sind sie auf dem Töff.
A man with three children.
* Er lacht. *
Die Fahrt über das Weinanbaugebiet
von Mendoza
war die zweite Etappe
dieser Expedition.
* Sanfte, meditative Musik *
Der Höhepunkt der Reise
steht Stefan aber noch bevor.
Morgen will er vom Ballon aus
die totale Sonnenfinsternis
über Argentinien beobachten.
Im US-Bundesstaat Texas geht es
nicht so beschaulich zu und her.
Die Tornadojäger jagen mit 130 km/h
einer Gewitterzelle hinter her.
Das Violett ist eine Tornadowarnung.
Es gibt einen sog. cell spit,
d.h., sie hat sich aufgeteilt.
Jetzt gibt es zwei Kerne.
Dominic muss sich entscheiden,
welche Gewitterzelle
er weiterverfolgen will.
Wir müssen uns in Position bringen.
- Ja.
Also, raus.
Und dann nach rechts.
- Rechts. Hier?
Geradeaus, ja.
Es ist immer noch
eine Tornadowarnung.
Geradeaus. Pardon, links.
Wir gehen geradeaus. Jetzt rechts.
Die erste Strasse.
Zweite Strasse, dann wieder rechts.
Nächste Strasse links.
Sorry, wir sind falsch gefahren,
weil es nicht nachgeladen hat.
Geradeaus.
Links, pardon. Sorry. Links.
Mein Wunsch wäre es,
ein wenig schneller zu fahren.
Aber nur wenn es geht.
Aber nach den vielen kleinen Irrwegen
scheint sich der Sturm plötzlich
in Luft aufgelöst zu haben.
Siehst du noch etwas vom Lefty?
Keine Ahnung. So schnell sah ich
noch nie eine Zelle zusammenfallen.
Obwohl die Wetterdaten
einiges mehr versprochen hatten,
bleibt zum Schluss einmal mehr
nur ein Regenschauer übrig.
Vielleicht
wäre die andere Gewitterzelle
doch die bessere Wahl gewesen.
Unsere Zelle sah lange besser aus.
Jetzt sieht die andere besser
aus und hat eine Tornadowarnung.
Die Zelle ist zusammengefallen.
Das ist ein frustrierender Moment.
In der Regel bin ich dann
sehr betrübt und still.
Ja ...
Die Enttäuschung ist da.
Man studiert Modelle, fragt sich,
ob man am richtigen Ort ist.
Dann entscheidet man sich -
und plötzlich
sieht man alles zusammenfallen.
Nein ...
Ach.
Auch im Thurgau
ist die Stimmung getrübt.
Die Wetterlage: Ein Hochdruckgebiet
mit Zentrum über der Ostsee
bestimmt heute
das Wetter in der Schweiz.
Im Süden und in den Alpen
ist die Luftmasse feucht und labil.
Die Winde sind in allen Höhen
ausgesprochen schwach.
Vor ein paar Tagen
hat Jonas erfahren,
dass er nicht an der
Schweizermeisterschaft starten kann.
Als einziger Teilnehmer
in der höchsten Kategorie Unlimited
fehlt ihm die nötige Konkurrenz.
Der 25-Jährige ist enttäuscht.
Ich wusste schon immer, dass es
knapp wird mit der Teilnehmerzahl.
Es hat mich betrübt.
Ich wollte mich mit anderen messen.
Gerne wäre ich vorne gewesen
oder hätte sogar gerne gewonnen.
Ich hätte das Training
gerne gemacht
für den Vergleich
mit anderen Piloten.
Das finde ich sehr schade.
Aus der Traum vom Schweizermeister.
Weil Jonas nicht genügend Gegner hat,
kann er keinen Titel gewinnen.
Drei Monate Training umsonst.
Die Absage ist auch abends
am Lagerfeuer das Hauptthema.
Für mich ist das Ziel
auch Wettbewerbe zu gewinnen.
Ich würde nicht teilnehmen,
wenn ich wüsste, ich werde Letzter.
Das wäre für mich enttäuschend.
Dann wäre ich auch für den nächsten
Wettbewerb nicht motiviert.
Jonas hat keine Lust,
an der Meisterschaft teilzunehmen.
Ohne Konkurrenz
gibt es für ihn nichts zu gewinnen.
Eine Teilnahme wäre nicht mehr
als ein Training fürs nächste Jahr.
Wenn du keine Konkurrenz hast
für Unlimited,
musst du deinen Fokus anders setzen:
dass du nächstes Jahr
an die Unlimited-WM gehst.
Mit dem Nachteil, dass du jetzt
Unlimited allein fliegen musst.
Jonas lässt sich überzeugen.
Schliesslich will er
an die Weltmeisterschaft.
Ich habe mir andere Ziele gesetzt:
keinen Nuller zu fliegen.
Dass jede Figur klappt
oder zumindest wertbar ist.
Das ist für Unlimited
ein gutes Ziel.
In einer Woche ist es so weit.
Titel hin oder her -
Jonas will sein Bestes zeigen.
Und nächste Woche
bei "Schweizer Helden der Lüfte":
verheerendes Chaos
kurz vor der Sonnenfinsternis.
Pass auf!
No, no, no! Not just yet!
No, it's too early.
Jonas erlebt
an der Schweizermeisterschaft
eine grosse Überraschung.
Ich habe von einem Konkurrenten
mit Weltmeisterschaftserfahrung
erfahren.
Dominic und Sascha jagen endlich
einem echten Tornado hinterher.
Eine Tornadowarnung.
Es geht immer runter und hoch.
Vielleicht gibt es Bodenkontakt.
Missionspilot Daniel
besucht seine Patienten im Spital,
und Misha und Christian
machen sich auf eine lange Reise
über den Atlantik.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020